exactly okay yeah if not i'll do yeah jesse's jess where i've uh in a few months when i remember it's
there all right all right uh well thank you so much for finding the time to chat with us i know
it's always easy time especially for you it's totally understandable uh we did put together
the overview kind of like the proposal how we potentially see you know taking shadows forward
to the mobile and how we can support you guys on these so i think what we can do there's not many
slides i promise uh so we can maybe very on a high level run for them and then we can you know go into
the questions um so ultimately we also would be happy to adjust if let's say there's more stuff
needed in today's kind of like overview then for your leadership to take a look at an review and
be happy to adjust it and add more or restructure it depends whatever feels best so perfect uh let me
start here in the spring i hope i can make it work
i love teams
said nobody ever
hey uh renata could i um could i just ask one question um and maybe just to
uh recap from previous conversations just uh maybe and also james i haven't met you
so hello
first time
and also fellow fellow bald person
fellow bald person
wait a second are we all
you're feeling unique
quick introduction i'm calling uh hi james um i'm the svp of products here at jaget so i essentially look
after all things related to uh making video games um so we're very close to jesse on dragon wilds and
shadows but also with the teams over on runescape and old school as well cool yeah pleasure to meet
you uh yeah my name is colin i'm a creative director here overseeing all of the kind of creative direction on
all the projects that we have um i am also a lead a product lead of one of the projects um that we're working with um
uh with void interactive actually um so i'm i'm leading that up and leading that uh the whole creative process of of that one uh really excited about that um and
and yeah uh i've been helping out with this pitch playing the game it's been super fun
uh and then building out like the possibilities for what mobile could look like
uh my background is from mainly from uh free to play mobile so that space is very familiar to me
um and it's actually only recently that i've been now diving into into more pc um pc focus so i think this is
like a perfect uh project uh project in a way and and i'm very excited like i think there's a good match
here i think i can provide a lot of um useful insights and and and uh and help you guys with
this one so very excited yeah yeah good to yeah good fun chatting with us it's nice to meet colin yeah nice to
meet you all right now wait now i have the questions um okay i'll shut up just let me know when i start
no uh maybe one thing was uh maybe we could get a just a recap of the current uh like thinking of the
project uh because when we were talking last time um was about the current status of the game that was
really early in uh you know prototype still doing the the dog fighting and doing the prototype for
that and no real systems yet not really sure yet about the monetization model would it be free or
premium at launch or you know that kind of stuff um has there been any um any change on that or any kind
of like uh direction given on that or is it still very early stages so we i mean we've had conversations
in the meanwhile so there there are some things are more clear to us than uh um than other stuff
that's still unknown but we are leaning towards that it is a uh still a premium purchase with some kind of
seasonal pass that that seems to be the direction in which we're uh in which we're headed together with
an mtx shop basically right so this is you buy the uh dragon wilds and then it's an extension that you
get for free right no no no okay so the shadows is a purchase uh okay independently of dragon dragon wild
itself right okay so shadows is a purchase and then there is a seasonal pass structure uh and a mtx or
cash shop okay and so mobile we could do something like a trial kind of like you you can download the
game and you can play it for example or like you know some part of the game and then you buy the
extension or was there any thought about the mobile version
um no we haven't we haven't given that uh a lot of thoughts uh just yet we're we're mainly discussing
um you know the the sort of the idea of subs versus the premium purchase uh uh like what kind of sub
what that means for you know other games in our portfolio like the existing mmos like old school
runescape would there be a benefit somehow um we're we're talking about uh pricing strategy um the only
thing that we did discard was going free to play uh essentially as in um the free the type of free to
play that makes you design the entire game around uh engagement loops and uh certain uh fomo practices
um okay right so yeah all right yeah i think that's that's really clear and and and in regards to
the prototype in regards to the prototype this this this month we are basically um delivering our dragon
riding prototype and that is uh and and after that we are going to go into uh more of a uh multiplayer
setting up multiplayer um massively multiplayer uh back-end technology and trying that out
um but after that we'll be moving on to building the vertical slice for the end of this year that's
the first thing that we're going to do after this period of prototyping to basically get a full uh arted
up uh one of everything uh vertical slice before the end of the year yeah i think that was pretty
aligned with what the expectation was before in the previous call i think that was the same yeah cool
okay yeah it makes sense um and then like on the terms of maybe understanding a little bit on the
on the broader like there's still a lot of emphasis on trying to bring the mobile version
like was there still an idea that that would be launched afterwards or then would it be sync launch
like have you i mean maybe a more of a discussion so i mean um i don't know how james uh sees it but
um it will be hard given that at the end of this year's vertical slice and then the end of next year
uh uh will be soft launch um because i know how development on this project goes it always comes down
to the wire right so it's it's like in every project that's that star fighter from battlestar
galactica which just makes it into the hangar uh like sliding across across the steel with a shower of
sparks that's basically everything liverpool but it landed but it landed yeah so uh you know parallel
development um we would need to be smart about that how we would do that and otherwise it becomes a
matter of where when is the product mature enough so that we can hand it over to you in in in some way
otherwise there will be yeah we will need to find some other path um forward but yeah yeah it makes
sense yeah i think yeah we can go into the details obviously i think that's that's also part of you
know some of the research exploration in this like mobile like rnd i think we can also plan out like
what would be some options for how the development could could work um i think you don't know that
unless you know more about the project and know about the details of how it's being developed um
but yeah maybe i'll yeah that was kind of just opener just to understand a little bit more like
kind of current state of things because we've had a few conversations yeah thank you yeah i think
yeah i think to kind of address you're saying timelines and mobile i think is a very big question
mark that we probably want to get out together um i'm anticipating we wouldn't soft launch on pc
console and mobile simultaneously just to avoid all the pressures that comes with that so my assumption is
the mobile launch would come at some point between the initial soft launch point towards the town of
next year and the full commercial launch which jesse we currently mapping end of 28 early 29 yeah something
like that yeah um but where on that timeline it drops is i think a very big tpd i feel it's it's
uh personally i feel it's more likely that we would be able to uh um that we would be able to launch on pc
and mobile uh i would find that more likely than that we would do pc and consoles to be uh to be honest
because of you know just console certification and everything that comes with that uh mobile might be a
a bit more straightforward but the the question is how would you guys stay in tandem with us yeah right
so let's take 2027 um like how would that work where we are developing the game and then you take
uh uh you take our repositories and make that work step after step on on mobile is that is that way to do it
um would that would that be horribly inefficient uh i mean i yeah that's actually would be uh maybe i can
jump in here uh now i'm thinking we should have brought you see here uh not the you see who was the
we have many uses this is the thing uh one of the use many uses that we have in the company who uh
uh i was leading the warframe uh project uh and maybe he would be able to talk a little bit more
but basically before the warframe we were doing the wavefinder with digital extremes and we found it
for example way more efficient to do it we were kind of following if we are kind of like in a similar
fashion maybe which what we're going to do with shadows we were following development pretty much
uh kind of like milestone after the milestone versus the warframe there was a game of already
with 10 years of legacy which we kind of was kind of like dropped at us in a way so uh we found it
kind of like uh very efficient in a way where we would be following and very close by into the development
especially considering that mobile kind of like is a plan from the get-go uh so we're going to very
efficient that way but then again it also depends whether you want to simship uh with pc and mobile
for example or not and how that launch schedule is going to look like well in soft launch we would
want to try out uh we would want to get a read on on performance right on the metrics yeah of course
monetization but also um yeah um uh dao um all of the engagement metrics uh that would indicate to us
that we've got something sticky yeah that there's uh enough um enough to do um so that we could do that
on mobile as well the only thing is when it comes to monetization there is of course yeah for us it
makes sense to have on pc the product be a premium purchase um there's many reasons for that but
it will be tricky for us to let go of that except if we find some sort of way in which
a sub like a literal sub could could cover could cover all of our um
could cover what we would need out of the uh out of the project from a revenue perspective
yeah but yeah so the sub would give you access to mobile is that what you're trying to say as well
like that you would get the whole suite of games in a way is it did i understand that yeah i mean
there's so there's so much that needs to be discussed uh around that potentially uh but
whichever way you whichever way you um
sort of cut it it would mean that there would if you do something like that it would mean that there
for people who are just mobile gamers uh and not pc gamers um how would you what would be the
proposition for them yeah right um would they have to buy the game then on on mobile that's
not ideal because it's not the the right ecosystem for that um
yeah that's why i guess i was mentioning the kind of the tribe you know you can download it
play a certain period of time um when you figure out what that unlock is and then you unlock the rest
by making a purchase so it allows you to get into the game but anyways i mean there are a few examples
that are doing that but okay okay yeah i would be interested i would be interested in learning more
about um which games have found success in doing uh in doing so like the kind of success that we're
looking for uh whether whether there are games out there to do something like this um
um because obviously we could try um try a lot but um yeah of course we want to have a strategy and
like you know what's the projections with you know how many down and yeah we would of course not
do this the thing is the the the one the one thing that i would like to stay away from personally
is uh turning the mobile version into a companion app um which i don't think is the right strategy
either we we do it in the right way for players on mobile uh but not but but not shrink the audience
by having it only be valuable to people who have already owned the game on pc for instance yeah one
game that we've been following at least uh internally is the deep brock galactic survivor which has a
premium purchase um recently when we looked at it i think it was already a couple months ago i can look
at it again um because now this is sort of new information uh amount the direction um i can look
into this more but this is one uh project that at least uh had initial success uh for doing this kind
of first uh you could play it and then there's a purchase to uh play the next world and unlock more
skins and um so that that's why is it is it is it like the shareware model essentially yeah exactly yeah
yeah that demo plus then chapter locks or exactly yeah
okay but i can share more information kind of uh sorry colleagues no it's good there is there is
there is various ways we kind of like also now in connection to another project we also very closely
discussion with with the app store and google play and uh kind of like exploring because it seems like
both of them put in a lot of efforts in regards to not necessarily pure free to play uh scenario for
the for the games on the mobile but also like various other scenarios scenarios here like also pushing
it through their marketing support and what's not so i think there are definitely ways maybe it's just
not necessarily a pure free to play but uh maybe it's also not out of route to take with this
okay did you already share or not about the uh google is that what you meant the google play
like revamp of the store yeah so they have a big project underway to revamp their their offering their
store offering uh what did they say something like a billion dollars they're investing into
like redoing the entire store of discoverability so they can make it more custom more specific to
to individual players um a lot like what steam is doing right i think steam is at least pushing the
bar in terms of releases on that and google play is doing something to try to bring in pc players
so trying to move into that space now um it's pretty interesting um and they have what was the fun
thing that they have renata well it depends they're kind of like multiple funding kind of like uh not
they obviously not as big as let's say the budget for the project would be but they're they're they're
open to potentially do some sort of funding uh on the those projects that will be brought up in the
in the go in the google play store and will be allowed to play not only on the mobile but also kind
of like on the pc the big question here of course if there is you know if you want to actually even
take that path there that is kind of like still a question mark and let's be honest the google play is
of steam and very far from it at this point so i think kind of like of course it will now they're
investing heavily and they um we'll see where they will be in a couple of years uh but there's definitely
seems to be a lot of effort and opportunity there for sure okay all righty shall we get into it
calling started just one question all of a sudden we
we talked about chocolate for like 15 minutes right well that's true that's true okay okay uh anyways so uh
once again uh just before we go in there's not too many slides so please join me and then calling
jumping as well so we have a first slide with just executive summary of what is going to be presented
uh further uh down the road um the way we were looking into this kind of like potentially going
step forward is of course to start with r d uh for ultimately reduce the risk and avoid the costly
reward so we kind of like we will be looking into uh the mobile things and uh kind of like
trying to not distract the main team as much as possible but at the same time thinking about the
mobile uh native things that needs to be kept in mind in order for us to then not end up in a situation
uh which you know we're getting closer to let's say self-blanch and all of a sudden there's lots of stuff
that needs to be written for uh for for that uh very much phased approach so we're looking into
kind of like going into phases uh as i mentioned starting with r d going into the validation
production soft launch and launch soft launch will heavily depends on what we will decide for it to be
ultimately uh so we're not necessarily putting kind of like any um specific budget in mind for the
soft launch it will be kind of like it depends how long we will we'll make it uh from our side uh we
have a proven track record which we've been i think million times already mentioning uh warframe is the
latest one the wayfinder right before that uh lots of experience uh on unreal uh and proprietary i know the
proprietor here is not that much of a relevance but still uh focus on performance scalability uh and
of course mobile first uh ux and ui ultimately as well clear deliverables i will get into those a little
bit later uh on basically on each phase we will have a very clear list of what are the results uh would be
estimated timeline to launch the ballpark here just because once again we get to decide what the stock
launch will look like uh the budgets for the simplicity of things we've put it in town so it will
be easier for you guys uh and a seamless alignment of ongoing pc uh console development or pc let's say
let's see how how how we're gonna go forward um colin do you want to take it away yeah sure um yeah
based on our conversations uh we put this together you know taking all the feedback um and you know
conversations we've had face to face and um i think so what we're proposing is this uh sort of mobile
research and development early on this phase um where we can help to um i think the first thing is
to alleviate and to discovery of any uh open questions that might have that come out of the
mobile game experience so like as we're developing we'll figure out um what are the things that we need
to consider as we move on to the production um and i think we learned this from working on warframe
that if you wait till the very end there's a huge development cost um and then the game isn't
really built for mobile it's more like hey you have a pc game and then you're building it for mobile
afterwards um we could go into that a lot of what that experience has turned into and and um i think
it's mildly successful but i think it could have been much more if had been taken into account from the
very beginning of course you know different projects but nonetheless i think there's learnings there
um i yeah we understand that the core gameplay is very much still in very early stages i think in
my mind what we could do is that when you guys are getting to vertical slice um we could already have
a mobile i mean this is i'm talking you know more of like we could have a mobile prototype that would
be the deliverable and then say hey like this is what we need to do in vertical slice and afterwards in
order to get the game the mobile version to be at um um in parity we could talk a little bit about
like milestones do we deliver you know you guys deliver milestone basis then maybe we take whatever
milestone builds that you have and then we update those i think that's one idea could dive into that
um i think probably better to have maybe sampa as well in that conversation but that's some of the
approaches that we've had with uh other projects as well um yeah and then the main outcome of this
research product this phase would be just this analysis i think both from a technical perspective
but also i would uh consider the user experience like what are the big scope drivers in the user
experience that like how much time and energy we will need in the development in order to deliver those
technical things uh things along the lines of you know latency networking um i think you know try
accounts you know these kind of things that in performance of the mobile version will need to
take into account um just to get a view of the land so that when you hit the um the next phases you
kind of understand okay hey this is what's coming this is what we know we need to do for mobile
um yeah and we you know uh be a relatively small team uh and then yeah we would provide all the
information i think one other element here is the design aspect or kind of product facing stuff
i think this is something that you know we've had discussions about um we're we are of course open to
to helping and supporting on that way uh in that way as well uh and yeah i think we'll go into the
phases in the next slides any questions at this point
no not not yet okay so yeah did you know you do you want to do right
it doesn't matter i can jump in and sure you you say you just saved me then later from saying some
stupid things so uh for the mobile rd uh we're ultimately looking to answer some questions uh on
this and in reality we don't necessarily even need a belt to uh to play this like i think kind of like
we're not necessarily uh we understand that the game in the prototype stage and there's of course
you know there will be some time until the vertical slide so uh as colin was kind of mentioning we'll be
looking into like what would be the difference between the platform and from many perspective
the user experience is one thing monetization of course as you know we're we know it's a big topic
how we then make it best for the mobile so that it doesn't become that companion app which we don't
want it to become what are the mobile native adjustments that should be made uh and the technical
and design uh decision basically which you know we could think of in regards to while the pc
uh development is ongoing um are we if we already know that the mobile is happening
and we we kind of like we can plan for it ahead of time um what device performance targets what
ultimately do we target the low end android devices or we don't and we focus focus on the higher
and devices those kind of things so all of this ultimately could be even started without necessarily
that's much of the you know we don't need the vertical slides for it uh maybe our cto always
disagree with me uh not really um so um basically all of that and we will work on it in the form of
kind of like doing all of this research and providing uh ultimately the results in the form of deliverables
and reports and how that's going to look like uh at least how we see the mobile based on our own
experience in mobile development but also working in this specific kind of type of project where the
pc came brought up to the mobile calling is there's anything you want to add yeah i think just at the bottom
just emphasizing the the deliverables i do think that it would be beneficial i mean anyways that like the
the point here is that we would more or less operate independently so like it wouldn't be i think
you we've done this with other partners that we have one person who's the main point of contact
and then we have checkpoints where okay hey this is the deliverable um and then you know we whether
it's the the build you know i think i would love to see it and i think there was some mention there might
be something already that we i would love to see it on the build as soon as possible that's more of my
i think to get the gameplay and get how it feels we can see under some of those um you know control
schemes or or user experience challenges that there might be on the touch screen um and i think that can
be done already like quite quite early i think in this stage as well um and then yeah like i said
mentioned before i think regarding the you know the overall product and the package putting together
we can also provide any research or any um you know perspectives that you think would be would be
valuable or sort of at your disposal there um quick question uh the output of this phase would you see
it more as a um kind of a document or a presentation outlining the same assessment of um learnings and
what comes next or would that would you see the output of this being a even even if relatively simple
high level of prototype on mobile of how the gameplay controls in ux could work i think uh in regards to
what kind of like the how we were doing that on the uh wayfinder and the warframe we we were even
able to put something on the screen what that something is is of course you know the question
mark depends where the main title is sometimes we are still kind of like looking at this from the
perspective of seeing that with the controller in hand not that much of the tongue touch screen kind of
like uh but then there could be definitely something uh on the already on the mobile device not the
low low end one but but the maybe ios uh higher end version for sure yeah i think before uh making
any kind of like uh or any basically before making any kind of statement about that i think
it would be important to understand the game itself and like the technical um i get i guess some of them
um doing a little bit of discovery sample opening up the repo and you know checking out the build and firing
it up and i mean he's been doing this i don't know how many how many projects um he will pretty
pretty quickly be able to understand if we're able to bring a prototype in the end of uh usually
it's pretty feasible i think we did that with um already with um well maybe i can't say but with one project
project yeah i was about to yeah i know i was like come on let me say no but we have one project where
uh we were able to do that within the first milestone quite easily get get something that is
uh on the screen on the device so let me ask you this then and maybe it's a technical question
but essentially um shadows of actionfall at the moment is the dragon flying prototype there's not there's
nothing else it is just multiplayer dragon flying right so yeah there is no build or game that exists
that would give you a sort of read on how is this going to work because the first thing that we need
to do is we discovered through our own r d that um a the the player character in the pc game is way too
expensive right for a game that is supposed to have um you know 100 players players per server
and the reason for that is because the the the player character was built
really inefficiently by people who were used to developing in unity was it models or animation or
what was the like no the logic everything behind the skills the combat system the way that how that is
networked um yeah uh buffs boosts uh status effects like one single character uh uh culture character is so
expensive that um it it's uh it is horribly inefficient and that's and that's because when our team when
we started work originally unity developers who learned themselves unreal um and what does a unity
developer do that that starts in a real starts building on top of unreal yeah rather than using the uh
unreal itself so that is that that is where that came from and we have never had time as we grew more
experience with unreal to revisit all of that but in order to have a massively multiplayer shadows we
will need to refactor the entire culture player character and that is going to take us a couple of
months um and as we do that uh then we are able to you know make a network multiplayer uh massively
multiplayer version of it that will be able to bring skills uh back on online so really
if you were to open up the dragon prototype at the moment you would simply be opening up unreal in
which we have built a prototype yeah so it would it would give you literally nothing in that sense
but what you could do for instance is open up dragon wilds uh in unreal and see how far you would get
with that you would get horribly inefficient um uh colder character that is way too expensive
uh you would get all of the bugs all of the trickiness but you would be able to make a
uh for instance a control prototype or um uh you wouldn't be making it you would have to remake it
uh once kuldra is is reaches parity with the with the character suite and everything else so you would
have to rebuild it but you but you could um make a smaller sort of control demo of how it would work and
yeah yeah well ultimately i think i think if you suggest that sound that that that path would be
much better of course i'm not uh our cto sample so i will try not to comment that much for him but that
sounds reasonable and then i think in regards to rebuilding once again at least based on our previous
experience uh we were able as colin already mentioned uh without naming the project we were
able to get kind of like the uh the playable uh on the mobile phone uh pretty kind of like quickly so
as a part of that r d phase already uh and which means that ultimately even if we would need to redo
it for shadows because we we're going to do it at the beginning with dragon wild that not necessarily
will be very expensive exercise because it will be a part of the r and d is it so that the shadows will
be because i'm trying to understand like it's is it going to be an ex like are you going to take the
code base from from dragon wilds and then like and use that as a base and then have a separate scheme i'm
a bit confused now i can't i can't i can't imagine so uh our own exploration uh has revealed that a lot of
our systems are too expensive so we will have to rebuild them um so while one of the most expensive
things about the game is all of the assets right so all of the all of the art um uh it is basically all
all of the content but we've got that we've got all the animations we've got all of the you know
special effects the the art and all of the designs that we know work um it becomes a matter of porting
that for us to be unreal native right basically um and that's what we're going to be busy with uh and
from that we're going to build a networked uh massive vertical slice um uh and that is going to
take us the rest of the year so essentially in a way we're going to uh be yeah we're going to be
porting the game ourselves first to to be natively unreal as it were rather than inefficiently unreal
and and you're referring to the game this is dragon wilds
yes yes shadows is not a game sorry yeah i'm so sorry i had to ask the stupid question
got it okay okay so yeah so basically i think the we of course kind of like the our main focus
at the beginning will be in regards to the rnt phase and we can as we go forward we're happy to
maybe kind of like add a little bit more clarity on specific deliverables in what format those would
be but then we also outline a little bit other phases which will be going forward of course vertical
slice validation that is something that we will be looking into uh i'm guessing and end of this year
when you will be getting closer to the vertical slice yourself so that would be kind of like uh
uh again it it essentially we can all also wait until we deliver vertical slice where you actually
have something concrete to port uh right something concrete to work on it um i guess it depends on your
tolerance for for for for the chaos of what i just described to you um uh and i guess our tolerance for
how much an r d phase would actually cost and what it would deliver yeah so yeah
yeah makes sense totally um chaos i don't think we're afraid of that but definitely not
we'll get to the part of the uh we'll get to the part of the cost uh so in regards to the vertical
slice and validation and of course the production planning of course uh we're kind of like looking
into this once you get closer to the vertical slices i mentioned we will have a full mobile production
plan you'll have a playable mobile vertical slice so uh on on that front we kind of like already seen
something much more mature in a way on the mobile uh versus let's say the build that potentially could
have been in r d phase and uh something that would ultimately kind of like bring us the confidence
can it smoothly run on the mobile devices uh what would be the scope and resources and the timeline
uh required to kind of like for what first of all potentially follow you and get to that sim shape
let's say on a pc and mobile but then what would be the strategy at that point and how we ultimately
achieve that strategy
calling anything from you i want to rush a little bit because i think that it's kind of like a very
standard stuff i want to make sure we have we have time for the chat afterwards yeah i think no i think
i think it's okay to go forward i i still sort of a little bit with new information trying to wrap my
head around um uh kind of how it could work but i i i'm there's a vision there so i think i'm getting it
there but feel free i don't know okay yeah then production i i'm definitely not the person to tell you
what the production phase is uh so of course we'll be here uh focusing on the kind of like getting
ready at the end of the production for the soft launch and once again what that would be and doing
the comprehensive qa uh and pretty much getting ready uh to soft launch potentially go you know looking
into this player analytics and performance evaluation and what's not so uh very much crucial
so i mean i think what maybe for for production to keep in mind is the things around because you're
going to be from production you're going to entering into soft launch so you need to have a build that
has for example first time user experience um i mean obviously production is the execution you know
know all this but it's more of um to understand that this is the release kind of release ready uh build
obviously there'll be technical and and uh you know phases within soft launch but this would be then
the build that's the first opportunity to get face uh feedback from players unless i'm not sure about
the release strategy here like depends a little bit we could do some early testing close beta that kind
of stuff in production in order to get some more feedback on the i think the mainly thing is the um
is the con are the controls and then also the um uh the overall progression like how does it feel to
and the feedback the player gets when when they're leveling up and playing the game
already and then soft launch and launch uh once again uh in regards to the soft launch as i mentioned
that highly depends on the length of the soft launch we decide to go forward with and ultimately
at which stage we will get to the soft launch because there's multiple ways to get there there's
obviously much more lengthier soft launches where you the game i don't want to say not completed at
soft launch but maybe has less uh at the soft launch and kind of like build uh forward and then there is of
course the path where uh we pretty much kind of like go full on with the soft launch and gathering uh the
metrics and do improvements but then the phase itself is uh shorter we gather the metrics we see what
whether we achieve in those kps
and we get into the budget and timeline at the beginning i did already mention that kind of like
the overall now once again it is the ballpark still somewhat of a high level ballpark based on
our knowledge and how you know things going so uh and as i mentioned we're looking into things in phases
so we of course not looking into going full on in a you know let's say signing the full project and
we're thinking that kind of like the first initial step would be the mobile r d which would be lasting
about two months uh uh and then we can kind of like just go into that uh see how it's going i think that's
that is also um very kind of like a good thing for us to see um how we work together uh if it's
comfortable for both parties and what are the results we can bring during the r d phase and then
we kind of like moving forward uh what if you know if everybody is uh still interested in going
forward with the mobile so and then after the mobile r d that of course that is highly up to you
we also open to go into kind of like you know progressing in phases or going forward with kind
of like maybe i don't know the big bigger uh thing that is i think we're open for for anything
on that sense but we're thinking that the best way to kind of like to start is only focused on that r
in d phase and nothing else per se i also have a slide about our team but i'm not going to bore you
with that i'm going to share with you slides afterwards so then you can you can okay
all right um
um i mean to me it on on the surface looks uh uh reasonable and i understand that it's really hard
to go into detail without knowing anything further about the project itself i guess that we would need
to take your timeline and your budget and have a look at where for us it feels like it would fit most
logically on our uh on our timeline uh i am just you know being transparent i'm a little bit worried
that if we have you start right away um then we might get to a prototype in two months time
but then there will be a lot of waiting uh after after that until we catch up to you again
um and that is maybe not really efficient for anybody involved so i'm i'm wondering like where
we place that on the timeline but would need to have a look um because we're working on that timeline
right now so yeah jesse my thinking is i can i can start um circulating the kind of ballpark
um budget with people like john and the board so that at least that's in their mind's eye there
this has been catching by surprise when we pitch it i think you're right i think the next stage
would be to take the timelines that you guys have presented there and map them to your broader timeline
for the project to see how this would properly phase and then once we've got the phasing and
the budget proposal together we can kind of go and do a pitch internally to try and secure
budget but i think um yes i like the costings guys thank you so much they're super useful to start
uh kind of having conversations internally but i think yeah the next step is what what would the right
timeline look like that works for jesse and the dragon miles team doing it the right way but also for
you guys at nitro sounds good sounds good is there's anything else that you would like to see
in this overview uh outside of the nitro slide which i decided to skip uh anything i can add else
so then you know you will have all of the information needed for your internal discussions
um this is um so one of the things that would be helpful is get an understanding of like how many
platforms on on mobile does this cover is it ios and uh uh and android what is is like what's but what's
potentially excluded um um i would say depends like what was the plan for the uh for the lol
lod's for console like what what was the timeline on dragon wilds
console consoles what you mean for dragon wilds or for shadows uh
uh for both uh uh consoles would be much much later um for for for dragon wilds it's uh this year in
september okay
yeah but in regards to the mobile platforms with this kind of like overview we're looking into uh both
ios and android um what is excluded that is the good question uh usually we focus only on those two uh
no but i mean i mean like for instance device types and um um i don't know legacy devices like what's
what's the usual range that for what's the range that you um handled for um for warframe for instance
like are there you know edge cases or certain certain devices that you don't do or is it certain
technology those certain chipsets that you don't support or whatever okay okay yeah we can i'm sure
we can pull out kind of like a a little bit of the kind of like numbers from the warframe but also part
of of that r d would be actually kind of like us providing kind of like the specs that we uh we think
that we we could achieve here in regards to kind of like the device and how low we can get without
necessarily it's basically you know you pick your battle like how how much you're optimizing whether
whether you know those very low end devices are worth it or not and that is something that's kind of
like also part of the r d but for from the warframe i'm sure we can pull out some numbers
for your reference here for sure okay yeah i think a prof profiling pass would make sense to
inform that to know where they're the bottlenecks the the largest bottleneck so in the research you
know we could do that on dragon wilds to understand a little bit more like like yeah where are the areas
i think animation is one that we've found as a bottleneck for one of our projects that we're working on
um because mobile has only limited amount of processing power so then that's where the biggest
kind of tends to be the biggest problem like uh challenge with that but anyways we can provide
more information on that uh quick question also from my side i i know that you mentioned that in
regards to the mobile you still need to approve the mobile purchase but because that is wasn't something
i guess in the talks before in in the beginning or uh so that understand does it mean that also
kind of like the r d phase is something that would need to be kind of like separately approved as well
would need to go through that phase okay yeah it all needs to be pitched yeah nice try we're in the
private equity world where jesse's only got the the pounds he's already kind of pitched and had
approved so yeah for literally everything we just go on the journey of uh get both together get john
on the side and then pitch it to the board for additional funding okay sounds good sounds good
and what are that usually kind of like i understand that most likely it depends but what
what that journey usually takes time wise it depends on it depends on the um it depends the size of
the investment required um um uh if it's a small enough number there's a world where our cfo can
approve it um but i'm imagining this is larger than that number so it would be a case of having the pitch
ready and inserting into one of our board meetings but we have a board meeting every month uh usually any
um budget request we do about two to three work weeks of kind of pre one-on-ones with various board members
to get them on site before going to the boardroom so they'll just all say yes and rubber stamp it um
so i think if we if if we if we said we wanted to get started tomorrow i think realistically we'd be looking at
two months to actually get the the green light to go okay that was good that was good yeah um although
it's it's i don't think we've done something quite like this for a while jesse it feels like a long time
we've asked for a the last one was probably a year ago yeah yeah yeah um so one thing i'm quite keen to do if we can is
jesse's obviously jesse's here obviously evolving um lots of thinking around shadows at the moment so
rather than going with an isolated ask for this i think we tie into a bigger conversation about
shadows of action for in general and jesse we probably start that i imagine through
the conversation i had with mark yeah figure for the jobs mark
it would so it would need um it i imagine that in order for it to be a fruitful discussion it would
need to have indeed the cost picture the timeline but also the benefits uh like what what what a forecast
what it might be delivering delivering and we are doing that together we have for the rest of the
project we're doing that um um this month uh taking an updated view so it could be rolled into uh into
there as an option uh optionality and it requires more work from stew and fox um in order to forecast
what what this could mean and then yeah i think yeah i think that's what we need to pitch right we've
got the cost from you guys already what's the ideal timeline jesse so when we need to start spending
that money and then from fox and stew um what's the roi timeline look like and then we can go and have
the conversation but in the meantime i'd say i'll start circulating numbers of people because i think the general
sense that this is probably going to be a smart thing to do and that the the roi pitch will pan out
um but nobody's got quite a sense of what the numbers look like yeah so um well i'll do initially
i'll chat with jen who's our cfo this week as well jesse to get her take on how best to approach it
yep sounds good sounds good from our perspective kind of like let's say in ideal world and i know where
this is not the world we live in uh unfortunately we're we're hoping to potentially uh do the start
day kind of like the r d beginning of the summer it may be even sooner than that in uh in case so
then when we when we get after the summer like we're going into the fall we have kind of like a little
bit more clear picture and then can prepare the team and they're kind of like all of the uh fun planning
stuff which thankfully not on my plate uh towards the end of the year when you guys will be also
get into the vertical flies and everything so that is of course something that would be in ideal
work from our side but then of course i totally understand that you need to also look into the
things from your side well if we're looking at kind of full time i don't i don't see any immediate
concerns from an approval timeline perspective it's more about making sure that the timelines sync well
with uh your development timelines jesse yeah so yeah i think i think if we can we can work on that
at the next phase how the timelines match up then uh as i'll start circulating this conceptually and i
think it'll be fine to to take the board on the journey
um sounds good i'll um i'll let uh uh carlos know uh the what the shape of the cost looks like and
then i'm going to ask us to and fox to um work on the forecast essentially as sue and it will be based
on assumptions about you know what what the game will do on on mobile given that we don't we haven't
entirely um complete conversations yet about stuff like um subs etc james yeah but um um it will be an
approach that we can take yeah yeah yeah and these are just you know just imagine that these are ball
bark because you know obviously we don't know on the production like how how much stuff will need to be
ported and or like put into the game so of course this is like you know a little bit finger in the air but
um rough idea i think one thing which is very much uh clear for sure is the rnt phase that one would
not yeah that is something that correct yes like very much locked number yeah i mean uh i'm not aware
that our uh board ever signs up for blank checks as in moving targets yes but um yeah we can we can
have a more discussion about that as well yeah i didn't mean to sorry uh just to be clear what i
meant was that if we do the you know research and development we'll learn more about the project and
you know that will also help to shape um that was the comment there yeah we don't want to have moving
targets no worries no worries sorry and then i think the plan is we will add into the deck a little bit
more in info from the kind of like the warframe experience on the target devices which that could
be uh looking like a little bit more clarity on the r d uh kind of like deliverables what that format
that will be and everything and then uh maybe we will also add a note and kind of like from our point
of view suggestions on the timeline to start r d and then of course that you can take it forward and kind
of like uh decide from your end sounds good cool yeah sounds great and thank you for this all together
guys it's it's it's really really appreciated now let's uh get it get improving it right now sounds
like a big plan and if any of you find a baby yoda i'm here willing to play it i um i don't need any more
chocolate but i might i might please do things like you can like i would really really appreciate
i kind of want to see the quality of these toys so i'm expecting they're really they're actually
not that bad i i was showing to the guys but now it fell somewhere so i i don't i'm not going to be
in an awkward position trying to retrieve it but i can share with you the picture yeah that's fair i'll learn
i'll buy i'll buy i'll buy an egg this evening and if i get a baby i'll let you know awesome i'll be so jealous
oh my god i mean i know that if i find one my kids will be like yeah it's mine
you have it for two seconds oh this is really nice and then all right
all right pleasure
my own kids in this way so nobody's stealing the doors from me you're stealing them from others
yeah exactly all righty thank you both so much updated back in the next couple of days the latest
so there's not that much information thank you anatha have a great rest of the night